musclée à nouveau son dispositif pour
contrer une résurgence de la pandémie
la décision prise par de nombreux états
à travers le monde à l'image de la grèce
qui a opté pour la fermeture des bars et
restaurants dès minuit dans les régions
les plus touchées par le coït 19
c'est le cas notamment sur l'île très
touristique de mykonos au moins pour une
semaine ici à mykonos nous pensons que
c'est une grande erreur de fermer les
commerces est minuit parce qu'il ya un
grand nombre de gens sur l'île et on ne
peut pas en avoir 50 mille soixante
mille qui se rendent dans la ville de
mykonos en l'espace d'une heure il
pourrait étendre les horaires en italie
des villes côtières ont imposé de
nouvelles restrictions fermeture des
discothèques ou encore généralisation du
port du masque en extérieur au danemark
également les masques seront
obligatoires dans les transports à
partir du 22 août en espagne pays
européens actuellement le plus touché le
gouvernement a annoncé un durcissement
des mesures
la première mesure adoptée concerne la
vie nocturne et la fermeture des
discothèques des salles de danse et des
bars à cocktails avec ou sans concert de
musique en direct dans toute l'espagne
l'heure de fermeture de tous les
restaurants et bars de l'ensemble du
secteur de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration est fixé à une heure du
matin
il est interdit de fumer sur la voie
publique ou dans les espaces extérieurs
lorsqu'une distance interpersonnelles
minimale de 2 mètres ne peut être
respectée plusieurs pays dont la gestion
de la première vague a été saluée sont
désormais inquiet face à la résurgence
du virus
vendredi la nouvelle zélande à prolonger
de douze jours le confinement d'auckland
la plus grande ville du pays
à séoul les rencontres sportives devront
désormais se tenir à huis clos pour
contenir la flambée épidémique
la corée du sud a enregistré 2 179
nouveaux cas ce dimanche
la hausse la plus importante depuis le
début du mois de mars
je suis inquiet les chiffres décliner
est à présent de voir cette importante
augmentation cela m'inquiète
j'espère que les gens font attention à
leur hygiène individuel portent des
masques et respecte la distanciation
sociale
des mesures renforcées un peu partout
pour prévenir l'éventualité d'une
deuxième vague
même si le terme n'est encore prononcées
qu'à demi mot par les dirigeants des
pays concernés
al'inverse d'autres états s'avance vers
un déconfinement à l'instar de l'algérie
qui a commencé samedi à rouvrir ses
mosquées ses plages parquet restaurant
après cinq mois de restrictions